[Música]
a
escala en parís aída palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y de france
hoy nos adentramos en la ciencia ficción
con el último libro del escritor chileno
boris cuerquia electro cante es su
cuarta novela policial pero esta vez
ambientada en un mundo distópico un
mundo imaginario que sin embargo nos
recuerda en algunos aspectos a la
realidad que ya estamos viviendo
muchísimas gracias boris por estar con
nosotros por volver aquí a nuestro
programa escala en parís mucho sonido de
un gusto otro equipo siempre bueno ya
les recibimos hace tres años
entonces nos habló de la sangre no es
agua que era la novedad que cerraba la
trilogía de santiago quiñones y ya
entonces nos adelantó que estaba
escribiendo una novela una distopía un
libro de ciencia ficción nos dijo dice
nos dijo yo ya soy viejo y entonces yo
utilizo ciencia ficción y no distopía y
ya nos dijo que iba a estar ambientado
en una gran urbe latinoamericana en
equis años en el futuro
este libro es sigue con la novela
policial electro cante pero los bajos
fondos ya no están en santiago de chile
sino que nos lleva a ese mundo futurista
en el que un policía de clase 5 uno de
los más despreciados en ese mundo tiene
que resolver un caso junto a su robot
un electro cante porque se ha lanzado en
la ciencia ficción hubo como una especie
de llamada noche mira yo creo que los
quienes escribimos lo hacemos mucho por
placer veis una de las grandes motores
que tiene uno al escribir porque
escribir es bien árido y si a uno no le
gusta no disfrutar del hecho creo que no
no avanza y a mí me gustaba mucho la
ciencia ficción de niños de niños
siempre fue muy fanático de asimov de
ray bradbury de los grandes clásicos de
la ciencia ficción y además grande entré
a leer a philip k.dick y otros grandes
autores de la ciencia ficción más más
contemporáneo bueno un poquito de los
años 60 70 80
y entonces siempre tuve esa pasión por
este tipo de historias así que me gustó
mucho mezclar lo que yo venía que era el
polar el policial el lugar como se dice
en francia con estos elementos
distópicos de un futuro un poco fallido
y un futuro que nos asusta un poco
también
porque la ciencia ficción también viene
a como a tratar de limpiar un poco la
niebla porque sentimos muchas veces que
estamos en una niebla que no vemos que
tenemos muchas muchas preguntas hacia el
futuro y estos libros vienen como a
disipar un poco la niebla ya mostrarte
cómo podría hacer ese futuro se llama
electro cante que es una palabra que no
existe como se le ocurrió
no son palabras que van surgiendo muy
rápidamente cuando uno va creando la
verdad es que el génesis de esa palabra
viene de los tiempos que yo estudiaba
teatro de mis tiempos universitarios y
que había escrito un pequeño
cortometraje con esta misma historia que
es finalmente es el capítulo 2 de este
libro y eso yo lo escribí te estoy
hablando allá de los años 80 y tanto y
tenía ese pequeño
argumento de un cortometraje y cuando
retomé para escribir un libro de ciencia
ficción retome ese argumento y lo
desarrolle a lo que es el libro ahora
bueno electro cante es el robot en
cuestión que tiene unas fallas y que van
a jugar un papel muy importante en la
trama y además son unas fallas que lo
hacen bastante humano
y hay una frase del protagonista que es
natalio el policía que dice ya me estoy
acostumbrando a su anomalía que es lo
mismo que comenzará a querer a alguien
me pareció fantástica esta frase sí sí
la verdad es que todos tenemos ciertas
anomalías y creo que la vida nos vamos
encontrando con quienes tienen nuestras
mismas anomalías y nos entendemos no
ahora es interesante la novela como esta
anomalía de este robot lo hace entrar en
unos loops de pensamiento que los llevan
a algo parecido a la consciencia al
darse cuenta que uno está vivo que es
que es lo que nos diferencia de todo el
resto del reino animal de todos los
otros mamíferos es que nosotros tenemos
conciencia de que estamos vivos y estaba
leyendo hace poco con que como están
investigando que la consciencia tiene
que ver con un mecanismo cuántico al
parecer y estamos al borde de una gran
revolución de la humanidad que es la
computación cuántica
entonces y yo uno de estas dos cosas
trato de hacer un robot que logra la
conciencia y eso es lo interesante no
solo tiene esas fallas el robot sino que
el protagonista de natalio arrastra una
especie de heridas que recuerdan
bastante a las heridas de santiago
lo que pasa que todo el héroe de la
novela negra es alguien que arrastra
héroe o antihéroe más bien no es alguien
que arrastra una gran fractura interna
una herida interna y que no tiene cura
finalmente pero a pesar de eso logra
vivir y logra encontrar o seguir en la
búsqueda de algún sentido en su vida y
por eso natalio tiene esta fractura que
está esta herida que debe ser una de las
más grandes que puede tener un ser
humano no quiero adelantar lo que sea
pero pero si es alguien que del que uno
se puede llegar a compadecer en un
momento o más que compadecer entender
entender su sentimiento a lo largo de la
novela hay muchas referencias
en este libro cuando leemos que se nos
vienen a la mente
por ejemplo blade runner
con robots clases sociales revueltas ha
sido una de sus inspiraciones
absolutamente absolutamente gran era una
de las películas que a mí me marcó y
sobre todo la novela en la que está
basada en la novela de philip k.dick
sueñan los androides con ovejas
mecánicas en una novela que es para mí
un policial neto pero en un mundo
distópico ahora lo que a mí me interesó
y dónde puede haber alguna novedad en
esta novela es que yo tan lo trato de
poner como en mi realidad
latinoamericana o sea yo lo que hago es
veo mi país
pongo un punto cuando yo era niño con
otro punto ahora que ya tengo cincuenta
y tantos y eso lo prolongó esa línea la
prolongó hacia el futuro y pienso cómo
sería esta urbe en la que yo vivo
determinado tiempo futuro y el por eso
llegó esta novela entonces espero que
tenga ciertos tintes latinoamericanos
también este esta novela futurista a mí
me ha recordado también un poco a matrix
se escribe en esa tradición de ciber
punk con un mundo paralelo en gente
conectada sí sí sí que es algo que vamos
a vivir en la próxima década con los
nuevos las nuevas redes sociales que van
a estar funcionando en un mundo virtual
lo que pasa es que ya se ha creado una
cierta imaginación del futuro con cosas
que funcionan perfectamente en ficciones
que ya se han hecho entonces uno cuando
entra a describirte el futuro puede
situarse en ese mundo que ya existe
y dentro de esos parámetros escribir una
historia y es lo que más o menos yo hice
también hay un poco de western o en un
momento también natalie de la
inseguridad de la ciudad vieja es tal
que la norma es disparar primero y
preguntar después si claro lo que pasa
es que natalio como tú decía al
principio un policía clase 5 y hay un
stent ir muy mala prensa los policías
los policías en general y los policías
de clase 5 la novela ya son la basura
lo último es los que tienen que hacer el
trabajo sucio y esconder la basura
debajo de la alfombra y natalio es
alguien que cayó ahí porque por lo que
vamos a ver en el libro es alguien que
si tiene sentimientos de compasión que
generalmente esos policías no tienen
pero por ciertas circunstancias que nos
vamos a contar él está prisionero de su
oficio uno de sus referentes lo decía al
principio es ray bradbury que en 1995 he
estado mirando el decía la ciencia
ficción es la literatura más importante
en la historia del mundo porque es la
historia de ideas la historia de nuestra
civilización dándose luz a sí misma a
luz a sí misma la ciencia ficción es
central en todo lo que hemos hecho decía
como loca con esta darse wow tremenda
frase
si a mí me gusta muchísimo yo creo que
en general los géneros como la ciencia
ficción o la novela policial por lo
menos latinoamerica no tienen ese
carácter no son tan son más bien un
apartado en las librerías muy pequeños
pero si creo que esto que te decía al
principio de tratar de disipar la niebla
y dar una mirada hacia el futuro que es
una mirada que generalmente es caótica
pero sirve para para quitar las
angustias también del lector porque
cuando termina el libro lo puedes cerrar
y decir ah era solo un libro no es la
verdad es y también lo prepara que es la
función que tienen los cuentos en los
niños y es la función que tienen los
sueños también cuando uno despierta y
dice ah pero era sólo una pesadilla
todos los medios nos preparan a los
miedos futuros y nos hacen más fuerte
creo que esa puede ser también una
función de la ciencia ficción pero es
una realidad futura que ya es bastante
presente porque con toda la vida virtual
que nos prometen con el metaverso por
ejemplo no claro
da bastante miedo da un poquito de miedo
pero también da mucha curiosidad y da
muchas ganas a mí una de las cosas que
me da pena de morirme pena o tristeza
porque significan cosas diferentes en
diferentes lugares de latinoamérica de
morirme es no ver cómo va a seguir
avanzando la humanidad y las cosas que
se van a inventar y eso es lo que más
rabia me da de morirme más que otras
cosas
pero una cosa que te quería contar es
que cuando uno escribe ciencia ficción
es también una manera de hablar del
presente porque si uno habla del
presente muy directamente puede resultar
un poco panfletario sobre todo como
hablo en el libro de clases sociales de
política de estructuras de poder si uno
lo hoy dice tal como es ahora puede
resultar un poco más fletar yo pero si
lo pone en un contexto del futuro y eso
es una especie de metáfora y el mensaje
quizás llega mucho más llegando mejor a
través de esa historia en un mundo que
en un mundo que no sea originario
nombrando a nadie directamente pero si
en la novela yo siento que hablo mucho
de presente como tú decías el principio
ha estado en varios festivales estas
semanas por por francia
estuvo en el festival de novela negra de
lyon en el este de francia que es uno de
los más grandes cuál fue la acogida del
público porque además sus libros que se
publican simultáneamente en en francés y
en español es mira estoy muy gratamente
conmovido porque en un principio yo hace
ya varios años que vengo a los
festivales y qué sé yo desde mi primer
libro y al principio era muy difícil
llegar a la gente pero ya siento que ya
tengo un pequeño público que me sigue
que me va a buscar a estos festivales de
la firma y qué sé yo así que estoy súper
contento del recibimiento y con muchas
ganas de seguir en este camino tiene un
grupo de fans que no serán demasiados
pero son fieles bueno pues muchísimas
gracias le deseamos muchísimo éxito con
electro cante en la editorial penguin
random house en español y la han
traducido al francés la red quinoa es
los sueños que nos quedan en la
editorial asfalto en francés muchísimas
gracias y bueno nos comprometemos a
hablar en unos años lo recibimos otra
vez para su próxima novela que también
va a ser una distopía sin que este tipo
que se cumple muchísimas gracias y
muchísimas gracias a todos ustedes por
habernos acompañado y ya saben que nos
pueden seguir por internet en rf y
mundo.com bien france24 puntocom hasta
pronto
[Música]